on dit philippe béchade et les
rédacteurs en chef de la bourse au
quotidien bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors c'est 100 milliards
destinés au plan de relance il va être
décliné en plusieurs volets il doit
permettre de retrouver le niveau
d'activité d'avant crise en 2022
elle ce qu'il est ambitieux pour cela
est ce qu'il est à la hauteur de la
situation actuelle 22 milliards dans un
contexte où les plans de relance qu'on
observe notamment outre atlantique ou en
chine se chiffrent en milliers de
milliards actuellement
c'était un plan de relance de 2200
milliards qui est en discussion au
congrès américain 2200 milliards contre
22 milliards
alors certes l'économie française est
presque huit fois moins importante que
celle des états unis mais 22 milliards
le musée moi mais je veux c'est c'est
presque une goutte d'eau à la hauteur
des enjeux
sachant que cette année par exemple une
récession de 10 me de 10% en france
correspondent à une perte de pib de 242
milliards donc 22 milliards par rapport
à 240 c'est à peine à peine 10% alors
que les etats unis eux ont déjà injecté
depuis mars dernier
l'équivalent de près de famille de 20 %
de leur pib en charge ce sera le cas si
le deuxième plan de relance est adopté
et il le sera alors 22 milliards donc
ils seront débloqués en 2020 terre
autour notamment de trois piliers
écologie compétitivité et cohésion des
territoires
de quelle manière ça un lien avec la
relance dont la france a besoin pour
sortir de la récession
c'est toujours utile de prévoir des
investissements on va dire durable et
personne ne contestera le bien-fondé
d'investissement dans la transition
énergétique ou la décarbonation de notre
de notre économie
donc cela dit la décarbonation en france
on l'a très bien fait puisque elle
s'appelle la délocalisation les
industries polluantes vous fait
fabriquer à l'étranger et ça fait un
petit peu moins de particules dans notre
atmosphère
bon en tout cas c'est pas là qu'on peut
critiquer le plan
c'est au niveau des des enjeux et c'est
quelque chose de de presque marginal et
là on s'en va vers la deuxième
confinement dont le coût sera encore une
fois très largement supérieur à 22
milliards et ça c'est un coût qui
n'était pas prévu il y a de cela à peine
quinze jours c'est à dire que là on va
se rajouter encore de la récession et
pour y faire face et retrouver un niveau
d'activité normale à l'horizon 2022
falloir mettre les bouchées doubles je
pense et dans dans le plan de relance là
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit qu'il ya
des pinces d'impôt de production autour
de 10 milliards
une aide au fonds propres à hauteur de 3
milliards la formation 3 milliards et
demi les relocalisations 1 milliard un
milliard pour les relocalisations
quand on sait quel est l'enjeu en termes
d'emploi c'est une goutte d'eau cc c'est
presqu'un un budget à celui du joueur
quand on voit les les enjeux financiers
alors justement il y aura un amendement
normalement qui va fixer les
contreparties aux entreprises qui vont
bénéficier de ces 10 milliards de
baisses d'impôts de quel genre
en contrepartie par l'otan notamment je
pense que c'est peut-être ce haut fait
référence en tout cas je me lance les
entreprises par exemple se sont engagés
à embaucher des apprentis
je dois dire que ça c'est quelque chose
qui fonctionne puisque après un été où
l'activité en france étaient encore de
pratiquement 15 % inférieure à ce
qu'elle était à l'été 2010 9
on a eu et recrutement en tout cas des
jeunes ont été pris en apprentissage et
le nombre et est même supérieur à celui
de l'été 2010 9 alors ça je pense que là
on est effectivement par exemple sur la
bonne voie avec ce genre de mesures
alors sur les 100 milliards d'euros 1,2
ce temps de relance qu'est ce qui va
être perçue par les français par les
ménages j'hésiterais à m'engager là
dessus parce que aujourd'hui à part
quelques petites heuzey 250 euros par ci
sont 150 euros par là on est là encore
totalement en décalage par rapport aux
enjeux
n'oublions pas qu'au aux états unis par
exemple les ménages matière se sont vus
verser jusqu'à 1200 d'heures par semaine
4800 dollars par an à et si cette somme
a été réduite de moitié
ça n'empêche pas les états américains de
mettre un complément on parle là de plus
de 2000 $ par mois en france c'est 150
milliards sous plein
ces 150 euros soupoudré
au profit de ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin mais là on a besoin de réformes
ou de signaux extrêmement fort
c'est absolument incompréhensible qu
aujourd'hui des jeunes qui ne vont pas
trouver d'emploi si ce n'est peut-être
un petit peu en apprentissage qu'il
n'est qu'ils ne puissent pas bénéficier
du rsa avant 25 ans ils n'ont pas le
droit au chômage
ils ne vont pas avoir de vrais contrats
de travail avant une certaine avant un
certain délai est probablement long si
les histoires de confinement se prolonge
jusqu'à mi 2021
je suis là il ya des enjeux là où c'est
la montée de l'extrême pauvreté qui est
qui et à une menace non seulement sur la
capacité de survie on peut pas compter
que sur les restaurants du coeur est là
la situation pourrait devenir
socialement explosive s'il n'y avait pas
au moins un minimum de ressources pour
des gens qui ont perdu leur emploi ou
qui ne vont pas en trouver
cdb salvat genevois avait effectivement
je ne vois pas effectivement où sont les
sommes destinées à subvenir à ses
besoins
cdb tchad merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions j'appelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la bourse aux côtés
d un merci